ja ich habe mal bist du bereich drücken
der boden ist geil der bonus grün der
boden ist mein highlight ist das gedacht
das ist was neues ich mich richtig gut
mega cool also ich würde 7 und 10 geben
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir eine
maxi king torte und früher war maxi king
immer so das gab es nicht oft meine
eltern fanden sie waren zu teuer und
wenn es das gab in diesem viererpack
dann haben wir uns mal richtig darum
gekloppt beiden schwestern und ich so
auf ihn so habe ich mir gedacht ich habe
letztes jahr eine maxi king torte
gemacht mit zu gebackenen biscuit bürger
und karamell die wir auch richtig lecker
und dieses jahr mache ich einfach eine
notvariante und dafür also ich hab euch
wie immer alle genauen mengenangaben und
in die infobox und ich starte jetzt
direkt mit dem boden entweder nimmt ihr
da direkt so kakaobutter kekse oder weil
viele heute schreiben dass hier die
nicht finden gibt es in einfachen trick
in die normale butterkekse mal tief ein
und gibt dann anschließend bei kakao
dazu da es ja eine maxi king torte wird
habe ich aber ein teil der butterkekse
noch durch gehackte haselnüsse ersetzt
wie kommen nachher einfach mit dazu und
zerlassener butter und dann ist es auch
schon der boden
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt hier meinen torten
regen und stellen auf 22 zentimeter ein
falls er die dortige umrechnen möchte
weil ihr eine größere order eine
kleinere möchte dann nutzt gerne meinen
umrechnung tabelle verlinkt ich euch
auch in die infobox ich mache so dass
ich sie direkt auf'm eine tortenplatte
lege ich habe mich jetzt für rot
entschieden ihr könnt aber auch erst mal
einfach nur ein back-up runter machen
oder ein cache bord wenn ihn nicht so
viel platz hat im kühlschrank aber ich
spare mir damit einfach nur mal so ein
bisschen geschirr und muss weniger
sauber machen sondern kommt jetzt
einfach diese masse reihen und wird
flach angedrückt dafür könnt ihr jetzt
entweder dem boden von einem glas nehmen
oder indem zb meine streich palette
damit werde ich gleich eva streichen
doch dann nehme ich dir auch schon mal
zum flach andrücken
[Musik]
der boden ist jetzt erst mal fertig das
legen wir kurz beiseite und kümmern uns
um das karamell ich habe vier versuche
gebraucht bis es weg also karamell zu
machen ist ja einfach aber wissen
wirklich diese konsistenz hatte um sie
für diese torte zu benutzen hat ein
bisschen was gebraucht aber jetzt ist
das rezept auf jeden fall gelingt sicher
da gibt jetzt erst mal zucker in einer
pfanne nehmen hier einfach mal eine
beschichtete pfanne achtet darauf dass
ihr keine zu kleinen nimmt weil wenn ihr
gleich die sonne dazu gibt dann schäumt
das richtig und das war es ein bisschen
ärgerlich wird alles über schon jetzt
lassen wir das einfach karamellisieren
ihr müsst am anfang gar nicht hören
könnte aber nachher also bei stufe
sieben von neun dauert das ungefähr 67
minuten danach kommt butter dazu wird
noch mal gut umgerührt und am ende
nochmal die sahen aber dann zeige ich
euch was ich dabei verändert und worauf
ihr achten müsst
[Musik]
so ergibt ja dann die sahne dazu und
merkt dass es dann wirklich deutsch
schäumt das ist auch ganz normal das
karamell kann dann auch je nach
temperatur unterschied noch mal richtig
fest werden und dann müsst ihr einfach
so lange weiter rühren bei mäßiger hitze
also nicht mehr ganz so heißt bis sich
alles wieder miteinander verbindet und
so ist es jetzt gerade perfekt das
müssen wir allerdings noch auskühlen
lassen auf zimmertemperatur entweder ein
paar stunden oder ihr macht das ganze am
vortag ich will das jetzt aber ich hier
einmal um eine schüssel und ich habe das
vorbereitet tatsächlich und wenn ihr das
vorbereitet am vortag ist es eventuell
erst mal zu fest zum verstreichen also
es ist allgemein karamell das noch ein
bisschen
streichfähigkeit hat aber schon relativ
fest wird wenn es am vortag vorbereitet
und dann könnte es in dem fall einfach
für ein paar sekunden in die mikrowelle
tun dann wird es einfach noch mal ein
bisschen cremiger nummer zum vergleich
das sie habe ich am vorabend zubereitet
das ist schon sehr soft ich werde gleich
noch in die mikrowelle tun uns einfach
besser zu verstreichen und das ist ganz
frisches karamell also das ist schon
relativ flüssig jetzt brauchen wir noch
eine richtig leckere füllung dafür habe
ich hier meine zutaten bereit stehen ich
fange an mit der schlagzeile die sollte
schön kalt sein achtet darauf dass die
schüssel auch kalt ist und dass jetzt
neuer schnee sind auch dass ihnen die
nicht grad warm up gespült wurde denn so
funktioniert am besten dass wir die
sahne steif schlag ich las auch
währenddessen zucker einrieseln und
sahne fest und gäbe dann kurz bevor es
ganz steif ist noch mascarpone und creme
fraiche mit dazu
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt quasi die basis unserer
creme ihr könnt es jetzt noch verfeinern
ich persönlich finde ja es ist lecker
aber es schmeckt noch nicht ganz so
wollen ja alles so auf ein neues level
bringen daher kommt jemand mir vanille
extrakt nach rein das ruhig gleich
einfach unter und weil beim maxi king ja
auch die haselnuss eine große rolle
spielt das ist wirklich optional könnt
ihr falls ihr meine haselnuss creme zu
hause habt gerne auch noch so richtig
dicken esslöffel davon rein tun und ihr
werdet es dann im anschnitt merken dass
einfach noch mal nicht diese haselnuss
aroma durchkommt und vor allem auf das
thema temperatur ist die auch so schön
weich gebe ich jetzt mit dazu gehöre ich
wirklich nur noch ein paar sekunden
unter und dann wird einfach nur noch
zusammen mit dem karamell geschichtet
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die schöne creme
verstrichen habt kommt die torte in den
kühlschrank und es müsste wirklich
geduld haben damit diese creme auch
richtig schön schnittfest wird weil noch
ist sie ein bisschen weiß sie braucht
einfach ein bisschen kühl zeit
mindestens sechs stunden aber auch gerne
über nacht also nicht seht ihr quasi am
nächsten tag wieder und man zeige ich
euch wie die restliche deko machen dass
morgen
so es ist jetzt der nächste tag die
torte konnte richtig gut durchziehen ich
habs jetzt aber noch im kühlschrank denn
ich bereite jetzt den guss vor ich habe
dafür zuallererst folglich kuvertüre
fein gehackt und gebe sie jetzt in eine
schüssel damit der bus auch für den
anschnitt gut geeignet ist und nicht so
knackig ist gebe ich gleich noch seine
mit dazu und die sahne wird erwärmt
damit eben die kuvertüre darin schmelzen
kann und um einfach diesen effekt noch
mal zu verstärken von seinem weichen bus
gebe ich noch kokosfett mit dazu und da
gebe ich jetzt einfach sahne und
kokosfett hier in die pfanne könnte auch
in die mikrowelle geben aber wichtig ist
dass ihr das nicht auf kocht also das
darf jetzt nicht hochkochen uns
funktioniert der bus nicht es soll
wirklich nur erwärmt werden so dass die
schokolade schmelzen kann und dann aber
ich bin mir relativ unschlüssig habe ich
nur noch gedacht gehackte nüsse in den
bus zu geben weil beim maxi king ist das
ja auch so dass der bus hat ja auch so
schöne haselnuss kerne hab ich was ganz
ich mache ganz spontan heute
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt die torte direkt aus
dem kühlschrank ich nehme jetzt nur noch
meinen backform löser damit ich mir die
seiten auch nicht zerstöre oder kaputt
reise denn ihr müsst ihr jetzt den
tortenring vorsichtig entfernen schön
ist ganz zum boden auch am keks boden
entlang und sobald ihr den thüringern
entfernt habt könnt ihr direkt in gus
oben drüber machen und die torte auch zu
ende dekorieren
[Musik]
ich bereits ja ich bin mal bist du
darauf
berufen wie schneiden die torte an und
legen auch so also wie schneidet ihr tod
ist immer besser wenn ich schneide mit
diesem torten messer das ist ja das aus
meinem shop und es kommt halt immer sehr
selten zur geltung aber ich muss sagen
hat bei solchen orten wo er halt noch so
ein so eine schokokuss schicht schneiden
müsst ist es super weil die klinge ist
so dünn wie notwendig die ist richtig
denn also wirklich wie ein blatt papier
und ganz oft sehe ich das und ich muss
ganz raus holen wir ganz oft auch rapids
solche mit familie sind jetzt in einer
ausgestattet mit dem messer aber dann
holen die sich so ein dickes messer und
man eigentlich gemüse schneidet und dann
fangen wir an die leute zu schneiden und
sagt sinkt die ganze teure zu rücken ich
krieg da nicht mehr so meint mein herz
pocht dann immer sexuell gbr ist ja ich
habe nur familien sind komplett
ausgestattet ich konnte es nicht mehr
ertrag
kommunismus geleitet dass dadurch das
sieht man ja vorhin der kamera
so und jetzt gewiss in heißes wasser
dann noch mal sauer machen und dann das
die andere seite noch mal schneiden für
die anleitung zum torte schneiden aber
es ist wichtig hier gibt es so viele
überstunden da musst du doch toll finden
dann muss man darf es nicht scheitern
es ist wenn der vermieter stellen ja
mein vater kennt keine gnade und er will
auch immer anschneiden
ja da wären die ganzen land dann ist es
egal dass geburtstag die schneidet zu
sagen
[Gelächter]
oder sind heftig ja richtig krass aus
seid lasst einfach mal diese entziehen
auf euch wirken kann macht seine stories
und dann sehen wir uns wieder beim
testen
[Musik]
so will probleme die maxi king torte für
euch ich bin einfach nur happy gerade
bin gespannt
der boden ist geil der wunsch mit karami
ausdrücke bleibe aber weiß woher das
kommt ich habe eine karamell schicht
über den boden gemacht deswegen schmeckt
der boden ausgelegt geil das ist aber so
kilger getroffen neuen verbrannt oder
sogar richtig lecker gar nicht bitter
oder so ist ja oft die gefahr wenn man
ihn kam er selbst macht da muss man auch
dass man es nicht zu dunkel wert war es
schmeckt so lecker wie findest du die
creme kommt das geld also die kombi
zwischen allen komponenten ist einfach
geil jetzt so
harmlos das ist
doch man schmeckt aber auch aus dass ich
bei diesem titel trägt dabei gute ist
ich kann ihnen auch ende problem also
haben sie die punkte würde es jetzt
geben 110 du darfst ehrlich sein ich
reiße den kopf ab das ist ein touch von
hans team hat es wie sogar der bonus
cool ja wo ist mein highlight richards
ist gedacht das ist was neues schmeckt
richtig gut ist auch nicht zu fest und
nicht zu weich mega cool also ich finde
5 und 10 geben
es ist nun brauchen bis ich einfach mega
lecker so ist er auch ich glaube jeder
wird den die junge leute oder wen
nachmacht und auch wirklich eins zu eins
nach macht macht nicht irgendeine andere
form rein oder macht nicht ersetzt nicht
immer capone mit frischkäse keine ahnung
was ich weiß nicht was macht einfach
alles nach aber die fragen kommen kann
ich das umsetzen macht ein paar sachen
die briten sprechen jetzt auch am
liebsten wenn man sich nicht eins zu
eins nach tagen habe man bei manchen
rezepten was austauschen oder hier
bricht lang macht das eins zu eins so
mein tipp an euch wir schließen hier
fotos mit ganz viel licht ist ein
bisschen warm sie selber deswegen meinte
von euch hat ihn einfach immer gekühlt
und kurz bevor er den essen möchte
cullinan aus dem kühlschrank aus dann
könnte ja auch nichts falsch machen aber
also keine reparatur und sowieso aber
ganz ehrlich wenn man es vergleichen
eine ganz normale also von der stange
dann schlägst du direkt so du denkst so
braucht millionen krise kann sich eben
durch jede ebenen den support geil geil
geil reagiert manche hier sogar ohne
witz wozu macht man unbedingt und
hinterrad unbedingt ein aber wenn es
nicht schon längst getan habt und euch
unten nike und sehr gerne auch einen
kommentar was dieses sehen möchte dabei
leute wenn wir sagen leicht und
abonniert dann meine so ernst es macht
wirklich also nein aber das ist ja immer
so als ob man überhaupt das recht wenn
man also wieso auch voll von mehr bleibt
dann abonniert weil
also auf jeden fall freuen wir uns auf
die kommenden rezepte mit euch schreibt
gerne eure wünsche in die kommentare wie
gesagt und dann sehen wir uns auch bei
meinem nächsten rezept
wer wirklich abonniert hat jetzt
wenigstens
[Musik]